Hey, Candice.
Hey, Andy, how are you?
Okay.
Good. How are you? Can you hear me properly?
I'm doing well.
Can you hear me?
It.
Yeah, I can hear you.
Alright, perfect. Yeah, my headset is empty. That's why I'm not. I'm not using it currently, so it's just a speaker. I hope you can hear me clearly. How are you? How are things so far? How's it sore?
It.
PH.
So far so good. I think it's been a good week. I've been a short week, so those are always a little bit more condensed in making sure we...
Excuse me.
We kind of catch up from everything that may have happened over the long weekend, but I think it's been a good week.
That's good to hear. The storm has calmed down, maybe.
It finally stopped raining.
Well, it's kind of sprinkling a little bit now, but we're expected to have like pretty much 2 full weeks of just like severe thunderstorms. And I live in a very wooded area. It's really great when it's beautiful and sunny out because my home is very shaded with all the trees. But
Ohh.
Mm-hmm.
It's also not so great when the weather kind of gets a little crazy because my area is the first area to lose power every time.
Mhm.
Everytime.
Gotcha, so you're used to it then.
And I every year I say I'm going to get a generator for backup power and I don't and
Yeah.
So, you know, we we are back up and running, um, and hopefully...
Akshay.
Mhm.
This will pass soon, yeah.
Safe that way, yeah.
True. Yeah, it started raining here also in the Philippines. It's our rainy season currently. So, but then I always tell you guys that we only have two seasons in the Philippines. It's just hot or hotter and currently it's hot.
Like, yeah, anyway, yeah, I'll be I'll be doing this weekly service call. This is just for Jericho, because again, it's we're going to do this for the next 90 days. If we're all good within the next 60 days and he's performing well, then we can move it to the monthly, just like what we did with Angela, okay?
Kip.
No.
Yep.
All right, perfect. So this is for the month of May, and this is covering past week before the 29th, because I think we had to reschedule the 21st.
Yes.
Gotcha, alright, so...
Agenda, it's the same: check-in, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, way forward, and recap.
So how are things with Jerome? I think you've provided me a bit of a feedback when we had that onboarding. He's been taking on tickets, but how are things currently that he's more engaged now with the day-to-day task?
Mhm.
They're going well. He's really responsive, which is phenomenal.
I had to do a little bit of training on making sure he's closing his tickets properly. He was just completing them opposed to the kind of pending review that I need for the end of the month stuff. But once I noticed that, and it wasn't very many, he's open if I have any questions or if I have to kind of
Mhm.
Uh-huh.
readjust him to, you know, prior to your critical ticket come in. I say all in all, he's doing really well. I think he's still, he's still learning, obviously, and he's going through and figuring out the systems. And I know that him and Angela are also working on some of the non-billable things as well to familiarize themselves. So all in all, I would say I think we're in a good spot. He's doing pretty well.
Yeah.
That's good to hear. I think both Tim and Angela are actually getting along really well also. So yeah, it's going to be a good teamwork, to be honest, because at least they're comfortable with each other and they can ask questions and all that. So a good.
Yes, it does in that way.
No.
Yeah, really. So, all right, moving on to our highlights. So, just wanted to give you an update when it comes to the training. So, Angela has been actively engaged in hands-on training with Jericho, including the comprehensive knowledge transfer activities that would include a backup that we talked about before, just so he has a bit of an idea of what those are, as well as...
Oh.
back up in VMware. So those are the things also that I ask Andrew if she can share a bit of her knowledge because again, there might be some time that she's out and she can take, Jericho could take over on her behalf. So because what we wanted to do, since you have two engineers now, what we don't want is.
Um, not the business continuity, you know, we wanted to make sure that it's a smooth operations with or without one person, so...
Yes.
At that, second is performance, of course. So from last week, Jericho has been working on tickets. He has been completed as well. Started this week, Angela has given tasks to Jericho to monitor backup that are failing via your tool, Altaro. So I think he's been...
Mhm.
On.
At the meeting, when it comes to your tools, as you mentioned, but he's getting there and I just hope he was able to continue where he is currently.
All right, next is monitoring. So what Angela did before, again, when I talked to them, I make sure that every best practice of Angela is being adopted by Jared Cole because it works, right? So I wanted to make sure that whatever Angela has, he owns it.
Mohit.
It does.
Also have, and that includes the gift. So, for audit tasks, you see, you see your score, you see what you did, what to work with, and if you're not even satisfied with it, then at least you know where your baseline is and you know how to come after that. So, we've also asked him to share it to Marky.
Mhm.
which is their team lead, so that they can actually work together. If he's having a difficult time when it comes to technical, then they can both work along with each other. So usually, Marky's working with Angela and Jerome already on a daily basis.
And.
I think, yeah, they're they've been catching up really well, but like all three of them, so yeah, it's a good team.
Next is Jericho wanted to express that appreciation for the continued support provided by both the client, which is you, the partner, and the colleague, which has been instrumental in helping him transition smoothly during his initial days. So he's very appreciative when it comes to the learning.
because I think that's one of the things that you would see here, really with the people that we have, is that they wanted more. They wanted to learn more. And every time that we actually give that to them, we wanted to make sure that they express their appreciation on that side, because not every company or not every partner does that.
Yeah.
Candace, to be honest. I have a lot of experience partner-wise and sometimes they're just so limited and sometimes they just don't have enough work. And here, to be honest with you, people are asking if they can be with Angela on this account. That's just how it is, clearly.
Love that, love to hear that.
which is fun. It's so healthy. So I just wanted to thank you for that. Because whenever they catch up, Angela speaks highly of you guys, especially you, and that she actually learned on a lot of things and be independent and accountable for what she does and what she works for.
Love to hear that.
Passing that along. Next is the performance analysis. I know that this is not enough data to actually work on something, but yeah, at least we have, we can see a bit of an insight of what he's currently is working on. So utilization rate.
Yeah.
He's at 19, 34, 22 and 28 a day, which I don't really expect to have for him to have this ticket or utilization, right? But it's a good start because our target, once he's up and running and actually live and getting the day-to-day tickets, I wanted him to make sure that he gets that 80%.
So the 26 percent utilization rate for his, I don't know, third week, I think that that one is a good baseline. So that's that. I didn't even know that he was taking in tickets, by the way.
Yeah.
Yeah, I always try to do a, and I hate to call it a test, but I guess in a way that it is, it's just more like a comfortability tracker. So I always start with just a little minor tickets just to kind of build that comfortability of contacting the customers, the flow of it.
It is.
Mhm.
Jack has the meter, yeah.
Um...
Nope.
Kour.
Oh.
So they have a lot of events there. They have a ballroom on site, a bar on site. So it's very multi-factor as far as like a full kitchen with a chef on site and all the things. So it's, and then we're doing some infrastructure work there as well. So
Ohh.
Yes.
Yeah.
Ohh.
Complex.
Yeah.
It's been a problem child for us for the past two weeks. And I think everyone at one point or another has had hands-on and DNS issues, just IP conflicts. Like it's been their days definitely, definitely getting some practice on some more.
Ohh.
Yeah.
think through type of tickets where you really have to dive into what the problem is and he's been phenomenal in that as well.
Which is fun.
Who?
Which is fun all the time. Every time that you get to have like any complex ticket and the situation is kind of different from what you're used to, it tracks your brain and actually make it work and think outside the box. And I think that's why that's what they love about it. So, right, so that is the utilization for Jerome.
Mhm.
For ticket closure trend, I was able to work on five, two, three, and one ticket. This is 2 weeks back, and was able to close 4, three, two, and one. So average resolution rate around that time is 87, but then again, more.
looking at very few tickets. So the next week that we meet, it's going to be a two weeks data. So we're going to see more of these also.
Yeah.
So again, we forward, see, we have that 25th there because it was for the week of the 21st. But yeah, so.
Yeah, yeah. When I update your slides, Andy.
Yeah.
Okay, so for the way forward, Angela will continue helping Jerome on new tickets, still with the KTE in the process, but then again, it's live now. Jerome is working on that ticket on a daily basis. And then I'm going to send you our NPS link. I think I should have that. I'll send it on this chat.
TA.
That is our quarterly, what do you call this, quarterly NPS that we send. This is for the first quarter of this year. I'll just send it to you. It's just a link and then you can just provide us your feedback on that.
Absolutely.
All right, perfect.
And then, you know, build a live. So I already mentioned this before. Do you have plans or probably your team planning on going?
Yeah, I really, really, I don't know that I'll be able to get to anything this year. I have a conference later on in the year that I have to go to, but I'm really hoping to get on site with something that you guys are a part of next year for sure. For sure.
Oops.
True. A lot of.
Huh?
Yeah.
Next year. Gotcha. No problem. I'll make sure I'll keep you up to date with those events. We do AI mastermind with Bullet is like the one that they are preparing for all year long. So I think next year would be a good space and place.
Absolutely.
for you guys to join. Yeah, if you guys, if you have anybody on the company, we have BOGO promo currently, so buy one and get one. Just let me know.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
Alrighty, um, next is, you know, Team GPS, um, or you know this, so if you wanted to demo, you let me know, and then we'll schedule that over.
Yeah, aside from that, that is it. I'll stop sharing my screen. Do you want anything at all to talk about, discuss when it comes to both engineers or even Jerome for the time you need?
Yeah, no, I definitely think that both Jerome and Angela are doing phenomenal work. They're amazing. And I can never speak highly enough about my team, and that includes you as well, and just the company as a whole. You guys are incredibly
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah.
You guys are just incredible. As far as partners that we work with, you're always number one for me. But I do think that they're doing well. And I'll always push and reiterate with Jericho the same as I've done with Angela at this point. Never be afraid to ask a question. They're no stupid questions.
Okay.
Ha ha ha ha.
Hi.
Yep.
and just continue to be communicative. And one thing I will say that I really, truly appreciated about Jericho is, especially last Friday,
So, you know, Angela worked 1/2 day on Friday and our other team member was gone, had already requested some time off that I wasn't aware of. That's another story here and there. But so he was by himself and I was, you know, I was concerned. You know, he's so, you never want anyone new on your team to be by themselves, you know.
Okay.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Yeah, definitely.
But he handled himself very well. And as things come across, there was no panic or, you know, he was, he was open to the task, taking it on. And he was very composed. And I really appreciated that, that he didn't, even if he, I can always tell with Angela a little bit when she's, you know,
Mohit.
She's feeling like, I'm going to do it, but I'm a little nervous. He really handled himself well, I feel like, on Tuesday as well. So he was predominantly by himself on Tuesday of this week, as well as half a day on Friday. And he handled himself well, really well.
Love you.
I said, yeah, yeah.
Wow. Yeah, I, yeah, I'll make sure I pass that message along. And the reason why I do is because, again, just like what you mentioned, you don't want to leave a new employee behind alone, because you'll never know what will happen, right? Either something will break, they don't know, they don't know, or...
Please do, please do.
You need, right? Yeah.
probably they don't have the great experience that you would probably want them to have, right? But yeah, he's very independent and responsible and accountable. He has a sense of maturity, I guess, when it comes to the work, the law that he has and the work ethic.
Yes, I can see that.
Okay.
I think when I was doing his interview, I was like, he's good. That's all I said. And then I passed him along with you and I was like, yeah, it's like a...
It's like a done and dusted. You've got to train him with the nuances, but with the work ethic, that's something that is kind of difficult to actually teach because sometimes it's innate with experience and that's not something that you can just teach in this 30, 60 days, right? So
Yeah.
Right.
I'll make sure I'll pass that along. Appreciate the feedback, as always, because it...
Absolutely. And it's funny that you said that because that's literally the very first thing that was said after his interview with us internally, when we, you know, regrouped just independent, you know, ourselves. That was the very first thing that was said was that you could tell his maturity, even in the interview,
Yeah.
Okay.
The interviews are always, you know, you always put your best self first, right? But I really got to see that in live action, that it held true. So you're absolutely spot on with that.
Yeah.
Kour.
Sorry, yeah.
Hello.
Consistent. Gotcha. Yeah, I think that is it. Thank you very much, Candice. Appreciate you making time. We'll see each other again next week. But yeah, I'll have more, I'll have more data for me to show you with his overall performance. And you know, you know where to find me. Just holler.
Yes, ma'am.
Let me know, and I'll send here the link for the NPS, so you can just click that link and that should be good.
Kip.
Yep.
Perfect. I do have one question for you. We are onboarding a new client. Do you have any desks for onboarding or best practices? I'd like to see maybe if you have something and compare it to what I have that we might.
PH.
Mhm.
Oh, sure.
merge some information because it mines very old documentation from the way when the company kind of started. And if you do have something, I'd like to kind of see them side by side as we're onboarding a new plan.
Yeah.
Um...
When you say onboarding a new client before, because whenever I onboarded, I was part of the onboarding and the previous MSB that I worked with. So there's a lot of requirements there, but it all depends on what they are, like the nature of the business, what they need, and all that prerequisite. So.
Mhm.
Does that differ from what you have or it's just generic onboarding?
Just generic onboarding. This is a very, it's a, they're a contracting company. So the only real specific software they use is an estimation tool. So everything else is just really just day-to-day functionalities. So it's.
Okay.
Ohh.
Dogra.
They themselves are not too in depth as far as what we'll be doing, but I'm interested to see how the information may differ from what we already have and how we can just make it better.
Okay.
Gotcha. Do you do monitorings for them also? No.
We will. Yes. So we're going to be monitoring everything for them. Fully managed services. We have our onsite survey next week. So we'll have a better idea.
Ohh, morning.
No.
Okay.
Ohh.
Got you. Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, Jeanelyn.
Yeah.
Yes.
and you don't mind sharing it all, but I appreciate taking a look.
Yeah.
Yeah, no problem. I'll send it to you as a PDF form, just like what I did with the previous training, and then just have a look and let you know.
Hmm.
That sounds great. Thank you so much.
Alright, you're welcome. Talk to you again soon, Yannis. Bye. Happy weekend.
See you later. Bye.